yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing fire spitter yeah let's see can
I do something else I recently should
sort of this funny move i'm going to try
that out this is one of the ideas look
like Cindy strange but maybe g3 neglect
see final bits out attacking it down
just make some sense actually aha so but
here I can take and play c5 that doesn't
look too bad hmm interesting I wonder if
a quick g6 help for him and wait um
Knight takes pawn takes Queen to f6 man
that might work that actually might work
I just I just have a bad feeling about
it now someone I don't trust that I
sometimes rely on my intuition too much
like yeah nothing's I'm just not
trusting the move it might work 965 so
he's not recapturing what is he doing
him maybe no Bishop g2 ever takes you
form connection problem or something no
okay now I just going to take care it's
a little bit like you've been only
without the be pawns pretty interesting
[Music]
yeah now I'm threatening yeah something
with something on the beach on the day
and so that was to be expected but the
bishop is not very stable now plus it
usually wants to be somewhere on f4 or
so to put pressure on d6 I'm fairly
optimistic here at the bishop is not
doing a good job down interesting
I wonder if I should just put the bishop
on b5 hmmm we should have five default
would be good but Bishop f5 he is very
likely playing 9h for but maybe then
Bishop d7 behind they are carrot
interesting provoke him into play night
h4 then go to d7 then to be 5 million
okay this felt good to me I'm attacking
the d5 pawn and i'm happy about trading
this piece if he plays let's say nine th
for I'm happy to trade it oh it's taking
a long time
you
nie Dage for I can't play rupee a
daughter maybe look the end Wow well I'm
taking too long with this disguise
taking it to extremes having spent three
minutes after 13 moves okay I can still
go here f3 i will take 125
hmm not sure that was possible actually
f355 bishop f6p shoot at 625 patient in
one I'm the piece down man ha ok so f3 I
cannot take on d5 this is not good and
three is strong
it's going on yet come on it's really
weird ok I have no tactics unfortunately
him I have to go back now white position
is ok here absolutely is but he spent in
absolutely excessive time
23 and 25 is a quite annoying now
standard yeah this looks dangerous but
Quincy five okay
why we go ya mean I'm also not the
quickest play ever but this is like
completely it's like is overdoing it
quite a bit okay so we have this this
unconventional opening here with be 5
i'm not sure but i think this is quite
interesting to play and yeah i don't
know what white should do it if he takes
it the first I think black can be happy
with he's got a clear development plan
and a pawn against see porn is a good
trade and here i think this this looks
okay yeah so here nigh txt file and the
engine gives it but says equal I just
did not trust this it looks like yeah so
this is what's the engine at the end is
recommending with them compensation for
white can I have no development no
development now i don't know i don't
like it so I played in benoni star and T
I felt I should be should be ok light in
three was a good news and maybe Bishop
f5 isn't that great 92 was gaudium yeah
Bishop f5 it wasn't i was thinking and
all these lines but 92 is to stronger
yeah i should do this so that on 94 i
have 96 ready that's definitely making
sense if i can trade something here
let's say minor piece of some minor
pieces i will be okay and him yeah i'm
also i think an of ok i should probably
just take now here there was something
that I didn't like yeah i was thinking
f3 might be possible this this okay I
have to check at the end i have this
check at the end that gives me a good
position even okay so that wasn't the
problem guided the game running white
was slightly better for sure but by now
i mean i knew that i would win one time
so okay okay the captures actually given
that's the best solution here 00 so i
have to take with the Queen and then I'm
definitely worse yeah well here in this
game ultimately a wide was killed by his
bias time management ok guys thanks for
watching